Welcome to Table Talk, where each week I unpack insights from Christian theology and spirituality
that help you become a thoughtful, contemplative, and downright great human being.
So today I want to talk to you about five reasons why people don't read the Bible and
how to fix that.
So the first is that at some point in the past, they tried and became discouraged.
They heard that anyone could open up the Word of God and understand everything on the first
reading.
And they jumped in, and somewhere in the midst of Leviticus, they got totally lost.
The Bible is not an easy book.
However, that leads us to the second reason people don't read the Bible.
They heard it was impossibly difficult.
They heard that you need a PhD in ancient literature to understand it.
Again, I think that's a misconception.
The truth is somewhere in the middle between it's super easy or it's impossibly difficult.
Third reason, they are too busy.
There's so much to do, so many people to see, so many YouTube videos to watch, so many Netflix
shows to keep up on.
I mean, how can anyone have time to read the Bible in such an overwhelming world?
Well, I'll simply say that it would probably be more honest for us to admit that it's
simply not a priority for us.
We always find time to do the essential things, brush our teeth, eat food, etc.
So really, the too busy reason is a matter of prioritization.
The fourth reason people don't read the Bible is that it did not meet their expectations.
They came expecting the three principles of divine love, or the five easy steps to forgiveness,
or the seven principles of successful living.
Instead, they got poetry and stories and letters to churches whose names they can't pronounce,
and there's no greater disappointment than unmet expectations.
That brings us to the fifth and final reason many people don't read the Bible is that they
have biblical PTSD.
Either they were raised in a tradition that did a lot of hellfire and brimstone preaching,
or they've simply wrestled with, well, we'll just call them the difficult portions of the
Bible, the places where the way God is imaged is not so much like Jesus, and when they read
the Bible, it makes them want to chuck it across the room.
Now, notice, it's not because they hate Jesus and God, but because they feel the Bible is
in more than one place unworthy of them.
Okay, so what's a person to do?
Let me be the first to admit that, yes, if you've ever read through the Bible, you will
come across sections that will leave you scratching your head, saying,
Did God really tell the Israelites to do that?
And I'll do a video at some point on those types of passages and how I approach them.
For now, I'll simply say that you aren't the first thinking Christian to come across them,
and that while, yes, many Christian theologians down through the centuries have in fact taken
a hard line with those passages, that just as many have realized they are morally problematic
and they have various ways of handling them.
All that to say, take a deep breath, relax, let the moral indignation flow through you,
and let it go, at least a bit.
Don't throw the baby out with the bathwater.
Because here's the thing, for all our questions and unmet expectations, the Bible is a book
that rewards reading and rereading.
Because while it is an admittedly bumpy road, it leads us to a vision of the God who is
love.
A God who is like Jesus, and it's worth the bumps along the way.
Okay, so getting back to how to actually read and understand the Bible, what should we do?
Like how should we be approaching this magnificent and ancient text?
Two things.
We need to zoom out and zoom in.
By zoom out, I mean that in order to understand the Bible as a whole, you need to have a feel
for where each part fits into the whole.
This is one problem with only listening to sermons or only engaging a Bible app with
its verse-a-day feature.
You're never getting the big picture.
So how do you zoom out?
Well, you need to read the Bible from front to back, and you need to read large sections
at a time.
Now, you say, I have tried that and failed.
Here's a pro tip.
Get the message version of the Bible.
It's a paraphrase, and it's much easier to read and to understand.
What this will allow you to do is to zoom out and get a bird's-eye view of the text.
You'll begin to see how this part connects to that part, how this person leads into that
person, and your faith will make much more sense.
All right.
Second, you have to zoom in.
What do I mean by that?
I mean take it slow.
There's no rush.
Savor the words.
Ponder them.
Don't try to read the book of Psalms in a day.
Take six months.
Heck, take a year.
Don't tackle the book of Romans in one hour.
Give a chapter, like, a whole month.
And if you don't understand a word, look it up.
Study.
Patience.
Slowness.
The Bible is a book with depth.
It's a book that rewards the patient reader.
But we need a mindset shift.
We need to approach it more like a work of poetry than a blog post.
More like a deep novel than a TED Talk.
So zoom in.
Pay attention.
Go slow.
In other words, to understand the Bible, you need to do two types of reading.
You need to zoom out, go fast, look at the big picture, and you need time to zoom in.
Go slow.
Understand the details.
And over the months and years, you will be amazed at the depth and the riches that are
there.
Well, that's all for today.
If you liked this video, please like and share it and subscribe to my YouTube channel so
you don't miss future videos.
Grace and peace.